foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
how are we doing today
[Music]
bizarre
zaw
cutie how we doing
foreign
's out baby let's go
hey Jared
this intro is cool
hey you guys are pink today
YouTube chat decides what color you are
and today you're pink
I like it
pink kind of day
doing swell
I'm doing good too man
good to see you guys
good morning we got a lot to do today so
we're just gonna hit it
I want to try and finish the game today
which could take a while
or not I have no idea but we're gonna
play today until we beat the game
pretty much what we're doing
so if you're down I'm down
yes sir Pro Gamer activated
Pro Gamer activated dude
you're in the middle of class I'm sorry
I'm sorry
it's hilarious to me that you watched
during class
yeah we could do chalice dungeons if we
have time
um
we'll see I just kind of want to play
the main game you know
yeah where is because we have two
umbilical cords where's the last one
good morning misfit
yeah that's that's definitely priorities
I love it
I used to do the same thing when I was
in school I'd turn on streams and
YouTube videos and stuff
locked in have a great day at work
I'm gonna try to have a good work day to
day get bloodborne done
kind of nice that that's my job now
Forbidden Woods we'll guide you from
there Forbidden Woods huh
should I go beat this uh
let me go get some more
vials real quick
this crazy monster
that I think is near no it's not here
it was in the upper Cathedral Ward I
think
yeah we got the abandoned Workshop cord
stop it okay
yeah you guys have been talking a lot
about cane Hurst and I'm not I don't
even remember exactly what that is
oh dude there's blood dripping
from the like
Windows like what are those like chained
up little prison cells or something
that's sick
oh it's the secret snow area okay
yeah we haven't we definitely haven't
gone there yet that's for sure
so should we go to the Forbidden Woods
in cainhurst or should we do the
I I we can beat this boss first the one
that I died to at the end of the last
stream
at least I think I can
get where it is now
yeah
yeah
there's a graveyard of the dark Beast
I really wish I had like little pictures
that I could see like what the the names
of it are if I played this game more
than I would just know where I am Yep
this ain't it
not the right area
okay then we'll go for the umbilical
cord that
it's uh upper Cathedral Ward
right
am I tripping
this is where we beat the uh
living failures I believe
it's not old yarnum it's not Church of
the Good chalice
secret it's hard to remember
because it was I opened the door it
should be downstairs
doesn't this take me to the Clock Tower
because I don't think we're ready for uh
lady Maria yet
it doesn't
I'm tripping yeah this this is closest
this was the other Garden
and this takes us down to the boss
I believe
somewhere does
wait there's a little hole over here
do I go through the window
[Music]
yeah you
thank you man I appreciate the kind
words
what up silly how we doing
yeah this is where we want to be
okay let me kill these guys
it's bumming this dude
I'm probably gonna get yelled at by
someone in the comments for summoning
somebody but typical
[Music]
's GateKeeper
I recently started playing bloodborne
for the first time after I'd be eldering
and I'm really loving it nice dude it's
good to hear
all right Damien
let's get this done
[Music]
[Music]
oh
well where is the safe spot for this
chick
it's not fair
[Applause]
foreign
Damien is almost there
so you're not doing the laser beams
[Music]
the music is just going off bro I can't
even hear myself
might have to turn that down slightly
okay is it lightning paper that's good
I'll use I'll use bull paper if I have
it Souls Community is definitely weird I
don't know why they make so many rules
for a game that is mechanics and
developers put in to be used
I don't either I will never get it like
if you guys want to go and
have a conversation about it in the uh
uh my most recent Community post let me
go get some bolt paper
on my channel go to the last Community
post this guy bro is so
he won't ever believe that he's a
gatekeeper but holy crap is he a
gatekeeper and he'll just never say that
he is it's insane
and he's all over the comments of the
community post that I took I literally
marked his name out and he's still like
just saying it's [ __ ] me you know I
don't know
get five
it's very annoying
does um oh I should use like Hunter's
Mark and stuff too or beast blood
pellets I always forget to use those
let's take these out
East blood pellet
bolt paper
my insight
supposed to make them lose their sense
of direction that's kind of cool
we'll try Brian we'll see what we can do
okay
here
no idea Prezi
the person next to me is looking at me
excellent
bone marrow on my gun huh
thank you
yeah orphan of Paws is
it's a lot
all right buddy
I don't know this boss seems okay so far
I think I just need to run to the side
with the laser beams but not get hit
not a huge fan of the art style I can't
stand those dogs
and yeah that's uh
it's definitely a preference
get it or is this not a beast and this
doesn't even matter
boom
it's like a beast to me
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
yeah once I got in between the legs
there
and Damien distracting
Gigi
the game you playing is better than
Elden ring oh I mean it's totally
preference
I think so whoa look at this thing
it's like one of the ROM spiders
specked
do nothing
okay clearly I need something for that
that's for after cainhurst okay cool
that is ROM
interesting
yeah I'm gonna have to turn down the
music for just the main game because I
literally can't even hear myself right
now
bloodborne better than Elder ring I hate
so many flowers
I don't even know what the heck you just
said
let me turn it down a little bit
like I can't hear anything
okay how do I um how do I get to
kanehurst you said forbidden Forbidden
Woods
here
we need one more umbilical cord
Ernie
that's ROM's True Body
let's go
too many flowers
and nice things in Elden ring
interesting
do I want to go this way
bro
age dogs
probably not how's our boy doing ah
there goes your hunt pretty good mate do
not forget the League's mission to
cooperate with Confederates find Vermin
and stamp them out that's what I've been
doing dude I've been cooperating
the guy in the game is literally telling
me to do so
imagine
straight path
but I think I do know what you mean by
the Caged dogs I think I do
is there like a side entrance
I think I do know what you're talking
about
it's like in this next town over right
oh yeah don't I need an invitation
I think you guys are saying that right
pork pork pork pork
it is down the path oh
are you gonna follow me down here
[ __ ] you oh [ __ ] you man
you are cursed the cage the dogs is like
near here I think
let me clear out the area
now that we're buff as [ __ ]
oh God
I'm gonna die some there's some random
[ __ ]
[Music]
I'm near it somewhere
nice that's six blood pellets thanks
I'll take it
hello
I think I got it through the wall
no it's my first run in like five six
years
so it's been a long time
since I played
dude didn't that
yeah I gotta go more left
that killed me the other day the exact
same thing
those freaking uh bombs do a ton of
damage
rig man
foreign
[Music]
we're good though
uh that's right I am standing in oil
what up chimpanzee how are you
I want to get my Echoes first
guys don't tell me specific directions
I'll get it I'll find it man
it'll be okay
relax
there they are
somehow this guy has them
if I need a lot of help I will ask I
promise
promise
okay let's go this way
left
oh
that's me
Glory Be
you know not the value you possess
but what was the pity
the hours of the night are many
and the beasts more than I can count
a veritable hunt unending
not even death offers offer solace
and in the blood
imbibes you
a most frightful fate
oh my
God but I'm willing to do your kindness
step lightly round to the right of the
great Cathedral
and seek an ancient shrouded Church
the gift of the godhead will grant you
strength is this telling me how to get
to the DLC that I already did I already
kind of didn't
is this telling me about something else
interesting
oh we got the doggies
[Music]
kind of sounded like it must be
something else though he gave me a
different item
oh yeah yarl Church
ill
with from software saying their next
game is nearly done what do you think
their next project is
um probably armored Core
I would say
oh
do I want to go down there
I closed my window I did okay good I
don't want people hearing me like yell
and [ __ ]
yes sakiro too that would be awesome
that's the goal Mr chimpanzee
well this looks promising
very pretty
oh yeah I played a lot of sakiro
give me give me
looks like we're gonna get poisoned
yellow light
and a ladder
okay that's just another way
real cheese for life
what would you guys rather have
bloodborne 2 or Elden ring DLC
this place is ominous
both that's a good answer
I think both is impossible
considering
whoa
foreign
[Music]
damn that moon is full as [ __ ] hello
stop it
this is the clinic
whoa it all comes full circle huh holy
[ __ ]
didn't realize
let me open this
Brian stop I'm telling you already dude
please don't do what you're doing
yeah a lot of you guys said bloodborne
too which is surprising
I think I'd rather have bloodborne 2 as
well
okay
not a door
popped up out of there
aren't the Chalice dungeons like random
for the most part
God no
he'll leave as fast as possible
admins knowledge
can I hit the bucket
no bucket
there's a ladder there
Elder and DLC with easier Melania
I think the last thing anybody wants is
for
eldering DLC to just incorporate an
easier millennium
repurpose bosses
free
it's [ __ ] crows mate
foreign
I got some insight
we'll probably fight Michelob I'm trying
to think of a lore reason as to why we
would fight mikola at all
if anything I think we would talk to him
right
oh is this the invitation Kane her
summons that would make sense are you
mean or nice
oh
man he was looking at something my guy
speak pale blood to transcend transcend
the hunt
unable to acquire
oh okay that's fine
they can go they can go away with almost
anything oh yeah they can do like you
mean lore wise or like DLC yeah they
could do
pretty much anything they want
wait is this
oh I see
I can't pick that up
this isn't where I started the game
this is neat
it's a vibe
[Music]
communion
look to see what these uh runes do
the games are consistent quality they
can do bloodborne 2 Elder and glc's Hero
2 or even a new world and it would be
fine absolutely
you know what they're gonna do
whatever the [ __ ] they want
and I will wait patiently for whatever
that is you know what I'm saying
oh
uh hello what are what are you doing
tweaking
God I'm nauseous
have you found this
progressing
see things me too chimpanzee I knew it
I'm different
I'm no Beast
oh god it feels awful but
proof that I'm chosen
don't you see
How They Ride rise inside my head
rather why has she bent over dog
[Music]
nope nope I know that [ __ ] sign dude
nope [ __ ] you
nice let's go no one once they start
tweaking out and laughing like that bro
I'm done
I'm done you're dead end of story
that's a birthing position
I've never seen well I've never seen
anyone give birth but from what I have
seen
from you know the fifth grade video that
they showed us
at least if you live in the U.S of a
woman giving birth
it ain't like that
are you horny yet Jake
the great one impregnated her
so is she like FIA
so many references to Elden ring man
it's unbelievable
it's like Thea uh Lane with Godwin
every NBC in the birthing position okay
so go back downstairs
I mean it seemed like she was getting
pretty Primal there
all right guys
this is here
okay now I'm asking where should we go
now
where do I enter cane Hurst
she got the tingles in her lady bits
apparently Trey I mean man
ready to go
nightmare Frontier
hemwick Arnold Lane
all right I will use the chords before
we fight gearman
it's level gaming awaits you I know
very well
I know
I think we should keep leveling figured
like we kind of die pretty quick
and Wick Journal Lane farewell
is that DLC
or let me check these real quick uh okay
raises stamina wait why whoa okay you
there
this race is five percent more stamina
why wouldn't I use that
um
visceral attacks Grant more blood echoes
increases Arcane defense increases all
defense types
make additional discoveries boost a
rally potential
I think that's okay
The Witches of hemwick bonfire oh really
bonfire
okay here then
why only a hundred people why are you
being a forehead can I ask that
why do you care how many people are here
does it matter
okay
scared
because you big Channel
are you like 12 or something like what's
going on here bro
your name's beat Boop
do I want to go to like the
like where I killed her
no I'm big boy
okay buddy
pass gate going the grave pillar run up
cutscene will start
near the boss area
okay
I mean I'll just go this way I guess
[Music]
you have all three umbilicals
thank you Dino I'm I'm glad you like him
man
foreign
yeah I don't do we want to use
Ludwig's sword
I mean we can
we want to take the time to level it
which I think I have levels for the most
part
whoa chill doggy
relax
how
it's a big hammer you got there
we'll see I kind of I really like using
the cleaver
the Cleaver's fun
how did that not bury you sir
not that it matters you die in Two Hits
what is my character doing what did he
just do
what the hell
my guy like emoted
is this your first playthrough I played
this game about five years ago and I
mostly speed ran to any percent
it's my first time doing any DLC
[ __ ] you
sorry I saw a glowy thing
oh
really Shin that seems kind of weird
um did a carriage just [ __ ] pull up
bro
question do you guys get in that do you
get in the carriage yes or no
foreign
well this is sick nasty
you all get in this Carriage you kidding
me bro
what were we told as kids
doesn't matter [ __ ] it dude
if I kill the horse do we lose the area
There's No Stranger in there
y'all got a lot of trust in these horses
then
I was invited
true you're not wrong
everything you were told is a lie
according to from software not me
oh they respawn okay
are they ghost horses
there's no bonfire until the boss
really
this is a really cool way to enter a new
area though I will say
like this if we get Elder ring DLC it's
gonna be like this guys it's gonna be
like
something weird
ain't Hurst
oh what
how the how long have I been here what
the hell
have I just been standing out here
okay this is cool
I love this
guys there's a lantern right here
so if I was invited that means like
nothing's gonna try to kill me right
what the [ __ ] is that
oh it's those little blood boobies
that's the only one okay you guys made
it seem like I can I couldn't get back
numbing missed
okay you know that was uncalled for and
unnecessary
I don't know how I feel about this
foreign
guys this is why you don't get in the
[ __ ] carriage
just cause you were invited somewhere
doesn't mean it's safe
I have no idea who invited me
I get in some weird-ass Carriage you
kidding me bro
hell no
all right let's run I don't like
fighting those guys
kind of annoying
[ __ ] man
please open thank you
leave me be peasants
or I have been invited
but
but
ew
ew Bots ew okay we're good
all right this is very inviting
your workers are crying to death
you good
it's like Cinderella
ma'am I don't know what you were just
trying to do but I don't like it
imagine being able to stab a ghost
do you guys believe in ghosts
I personally do not believe in ghosts
but I can't say that there isn't either
because I don't know
ghosts are stupid I am a ghost
you can also have crying
[Music]
it goes
holy [ __ ] this is so creepy
this is so creepy
foreign
ing the furniture
ma'am it'll be okay
because you're dead
no I don't believe in ghosts but like I
said I also like I can't prove that
there isn't or is like
so that's what I say about everything
not everything but you know
if I don't know I'd just be like yeah I
got an opinion but
I don't know it could be
hi Stan
scared is there more down here
hi Robert just because I haven't seen
them doesn't mean they don't exist but
I'm not real confident they do because
I've definitely talked mad [ __ ] to a
ghost and they've never shown themselves
to me that's what I'm saying dude
I've been a scary ass house before I've
been like there any ghosts in this [ __ ]
huh they don't do nothing
I agree
okay I think we gotta keep going
I missed a weapon so who are these
people
they look very important and
sophisticated in rich
you know what I say to them
[ __ ] you're a lamb
[ __ ] your table
he Adams Family
[Laughter]
Jake I beat Melania new game plus three
no summons that's what I'm talking about
bro good [ __ ]
they're cainhurst douchebags
why did they pick this area to build a
castle it seems cold as [ __ ]
we just leaving statues in the middle of
nowhere
foreign
oh my God I had a heart attack let me go
dog
that scared the [ __ ] out of me
where you at you're not grabbing me
again [ __ ]
foreign
that's gotta be yharnam over there right
so there was this like a big bridge this
like Elden ring
except an elder ring we could go over
there like right now if we wanted
which technically we can
what up bro LOL
I can upgrade wait no I can't I need a
rock or whatever
I need One Singular Rock upgrade or
something
it's good to hear fiction I'm glad man
the bridge is broken
Peru
can you imagine if like
from software decided to like go all out
God damn it
to go all out at only a horror game
which I think is what they did here like
this is a horror game
so never mind they already did it
oh
kind of thick though you see that [ __ ]
damn
bro
hey we cool nope
yeah I have the three umbilical cords
hey
there are two blood rocks in bloodborne
not counting the Chalice dungeons
one
is Menses and the other is a place after
Maria okay thank you
then we gotta be lady Maria with what we
got and then we can upgrade last time I
guess
all right what's gonna jump out and eat
me
there it is
these not the bats from elderman
have I not done mensis
it's not a horror game it's a future
dating simulator
excellent
I failed to know where the dating
simulator is in this
but if if that's what you're seeing then
that's what you're seeing
[Music]
vile blood register
oh the the doll okay I see what you're
saying
okay so that's a shortcut
got it excellent
I could propose to the queen of
Pinehurst
what if I don't want to
can I murder her instead
because I'm a Hunter and a hunter must
hunt
stop yelling oh my God
so much crying my guy God damn
I see I need I just need to be a gamer
here real quick guys
yay
check that out boom
Evelyn
the [ __ ]
bloodborne's the worst in the series you
gotta be capping on a stack right now
squeal a squilla dude
squill a squilla you capping on a stack
right now bro
that's the best gun
who's spitting on me bro
yeah I don't know why I'm talking like
this right now
foreign
blow darts at me bro
[ __ ] you
yeah no shot
Dark Souls 2 is the worst one
listen
press one in chat
if all of the games are good in their
own way
Souls 2.
oh you kind of hurt
I like that you kind of hurt
the
they're all good
okay
all the games are good
you know what's a bad game
and press I want you to type 69 in chat
if you agree with this one you know it's
a bad game Battlefield 2042 2047 I don't
even remember the [ __ ] date of it the
most recent Battlefield that game sucks
that game is poop
at least none of those games none of
these games release like that [ __ ]
also I think it's fun to type 69.
see
yeah I didn't play it either but I could
tell just from watching that game is
butt cheeks
I think they updated though
yo I need all these girls to quit crying
bro
it's not that deep my guy
okay you guys said this gun is good
I can't even use it
we get 18 blood tinge
never gonna be able to use it
they're crying for me why
I'm doing great right
I feel good
have you ever played God of War yes
I am excited for the new one
that we will play on stream when it
releases
is this where I just was no this is a
whole other area huh
but
you
you
hey they're gone they're gone they're
gone
will you do lore on God of War Ragnarok
whoa that looks sick
what is this drip
uh probably not
because I don't think that's a thing
like the lore is all out there for you
my guy
oh look at me
oh [ __ ]
I got a different hat Maybe
yeah a little Top Hat action oh my God
I'm looking spiffy
Jake am I gay Maybe
I think that's uh that's on you my guy
drip born looking mighty Dapper guys
Executioner's gloves
wait these like actual like gloves I can
wear
is it gauntlets or gloves
yo does that work kinda I like this
this is not what I grabbed
I think it was an item all right where
am I going what am I doing
you'll stop crying
up
am I blind hello hello
oh there's a ladder okay
hey yo bet bet
you guys tell I'm like in a weird goofy
mood right now
I don't know what's going on
I'm feeling a little goofy movie right
now
okay I see the ladder
it's not a [ __ ] ladder
not a ladder
you're always Goofy
I don't think I can be as goofy as I am
and make legitimate lore videos
because so many people have been like
dude you are nothing like the videos you
make and I'm like true I true
I need to make like meme
compilations of these streams
then it'll match
yeah I think I I don't see anything out
here
okay little little traversal
there we go
bloodborne versus Elden ring
all right guys here's my opinion you
ready for my opinion and it's an opinion
that you can agree or disagree with on
and that's fine you don't gotta call me
an idiot for saying it bloodborne is the
best game ever made
Eldon ring is the best open world game
ever made
I don't even think that's too far of a
stretch honestly
Dark Souls 2 sucks because I don't like
it
there's an opinion for you huh
you know why Dark Souls 2 sucks because
I don't [ __ ] like it
imagine
why don't you like it I don't like it
laughs
but that doesn't mean it's bad bro it is
okay I see it I see the ladder
got you got she got you got you gotcha
too late already calling me idiot that's
fine I don't mind
you can call me an idiot
you know why
because I am an idiot
I'll admit it I'm not very smart
like don't care
is this 60 FPS
no
sorry I'm feeling very Dapper in my new
clothes
warm blood gemstone excellent
what is coming after me right now
something is running
it's good for my gun I can put gemstones
on my gun
okay
who sponsored this stream
who the heck is Scotty scroody mcbooger
balls
you just wanted the TTS guy to say
scrotie mcbooger balls
thank you for the two dollars Trey I
appreciate it thank you
why does Dark Souls 2 suck I don't know
I just don't like the gank fights that's
all
that's all
I think the game is actually fine I'm
just kidding
I just personally don't like it
we're doing a lot of like platforming
here
so guys is the boss coming up
is he hard
very
good
good good okay
um
good
right
wait wait
where's the one that I can use but if I
die I just won't
you know
awaken Anew without using blood Echoes
will that take me back
or will it keep me here
it will take me back okay
um
do you recommend me doing that
I open all the shortcuts
because I feel like we're uh it's gonna
be up there man I really I just feel it
in my bones
okay
I think I unlocked the shortcut
all right
I'm scared
nah this is it
okay I want to know the path back I'm
sorry guys we got a lot of we got a lot
of [ __ ] I don't want to lose it
that'd be bad
I'm dumb dumb dumb
we're going back
we'll get the path down because guess
what I'm gonna die it's gonna happen
it's inevitable
nice
man I love having literal umbilical
cords
in my backpack
am I scared yes
yes I am
absolutely jamming awaits you go on
very well let me
what do we level
yeah one
but
we're not we're not fighting the final
boss yet I I will remember to use the
chords before gearman
absolutely
thank you name I can't pronounce I'm
glad you like it
all right let's go back
we got all three chords
um
I'm ready I'm scared
where was it
am I even in the right spot
do I have a cold blood
this guy says use a cold blood that I
don't have dog
you kidding me
let me see if I can sell stuff
you know what I'm doing right now I'm
stalling
because I'm scared
just common stalling tactics
guys I don't think I'm gonna use Evelyn
because we are not going to get our
blood tinged up that many levels anytime
soon
I will keep it however
I have 200 gloves
don't need that
um man these don't give [ __ ]
whatever whatever it's fine
okay where's the other DLC Tim
it's not this one
the budgets don't even give us that much
[ __ ]
these are the Chalice dungeons it's not
DLC
wait are you super real right now
gain her cainhurst's main game
dude
I did not experience this game to its
fullest at all man you guys are just
Awakening everything with me right now
it's crazy
you know what chat
thank you
I appreciate y'all
and never speed run a game dude I'm
telling you right now just don't do it
okay there we go
yes you're granting me eyes
I just played like the base game I
didn't I didn't check online and see if
there was anything like anything extra
to do
I feel like I haven't even become a
gamer
or I wasn't even a gamer
we Grant two eyes
nice all right so
I mean
we gotta go up
three
you just gotta give the same energy back
guys
there's the ladder
foreign
stop shooting me
you [ __ ]
what
I
thoughts are dead
okay no more stalling
no more stalling it's time
this is quite the run back
I don't believe the crow lady is dead
foreign
yo
foreign
like this guy's gonna be easy he's
[ __ ] Frozen
just been up here freezing to death I
guess
hello
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's gonna be fine this isn't even gonna
be hard
all right guys
let's see what you got brother
okay
good start
foreign
oh come on
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
I can kill the sword
not a bad first attempt at all though
pretty good
very good okay I'm not as scared
I'm not as scared now
in does he have a second does he have a
stage two
that I haven't seen or was was that the
stage two
I kind of preferred the stage too
because I could actually Parry his
attacks he does a lot of magic in the
first stage
it seemed like he was just kind of
spraying it and I'm like all right
whatever I don't care
are you winning son
not yet dad
well
son you're trash if you haven't won yet
if you don't win on the first attempt
you're literally dog [ __ ]
and uh you're no longer my son
okay Dad
see you on Christmas no you won't son
[ __ ] you
okay that run back isn't that bad
love you too Dad foreign
yeah can I use his weapon
kinda like it
all right guys I would make up the
excuse that uh I'm gonna go get some
milk but I don't really I just don't
care about you
that's why I'm leaving
LOL W in the chat
thank you
he's already doing it
oh come on man
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
how many parries
three or four
round of illusions
is that an actual hat
yeah
just wiping uh wiping my shoulders off
equip it
yo it's an actual crown
hi
IM King Von Winkle shot
the Perry God
Von Winkle shot
will visceral you to death
it's not even hard
you're all trash in my opinion Von
Winkle shot welcomes you to my humble
abode
so did I have to wear the crown for this
to happen
yeah okay
am I gonna be the Frozen King
oh
meet
put this on to reveal secret casual
illusion okay
this is why I have you guys
it's like Dark Souls
Covenant
Lantern
I hit the lantern right
why are you making me think I didn't
maybe I didn't
I was being Von winkleshart
why is there pee in the snow
okay thank you
look at this right here there's
literally pee in the snow right there in
here
and over there
oh there's another Lantern
is this the queen
I claim no subject
but here lieth
up Neil lephorus
or get be gone
um
okay
do I kneel chat
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
we shall not give audience to an
ill-mannered Beast
we shall not give all to get thee gone
oh
Lantern
no I have not been here before
hello
okay you guys say to Neil so
okay
visitor hello
hello
I am annalize queen of Castle cainhurst
ruler of the vile
and sworn enemy of the church
oh yet our people are murdered
and we are prisoner to this wretched
mask what is it that in search of
is this what I should do
I'll get the item I'll get the item guys
behold tight cheeks therefore raise the
message
we've tired of these piteous nights
I'm tired of these nights too dog you
know what also I'm also tired of these
[ __ ] Bots dude against the church
[ __ ] you in your best adult dating site
partake of my rotted blood
excuse me what do you want me to do with
you huh not a vampire honey I'm not very
well
but I'll do it I'll do it if you want
black
now
there are two of vile blood
is this me and her
the very last on this
deal
okay
respect
offer blood drug I do not have blood
drag we await thy return
for the honor of cainhurst
bet
Queen lick my balls
unopened summons
interesting
interesting does this area not remind
you guys of the Shaded Castle
like with all the statues just laying
around everywhere
I can buy cool armor now
yeah let's go see
uh PVP gotcha gotcha gotcha that's
pretty cool
totally a shaded Castle thing I mean it
can't be a callback because this game
came out seven years before Elden ring
so
we did find Patches earlier
I have to give the summon to Alfred
uh where's Alfred currently
way to see the guy in um
the cathedral Ward here
I'm gonna go here anyway
there's so much to do
so much to do so much to see
so what's wrong with hanging the
backswinge you never know if you won't
go
you never shine if you don't know oh hey
now you're a rock star ah
alive and well are ya this here is a
safe place stay as long as you like how
do you not know who I am
next time you're out on a hunt but what
I asked
you find anything yeah yeah
nothing I know if you happen upon
someone if they're seeing well is this
not the guy this ain't Alfred
are we still insane over here
[Laughter]
excellent good
Alfred's before the woods okay so he's
over here to the left
over here to the right
left
play sakiro
um I definitely want to finish the Kiro
I think we should after we beat this
game
I played secure I have a lot of hours in
sakuro I just not on stream I've only
played it on stream once
I went too far
[ __ ]
oh God I'm lost
see I thought the Forbidden Woods was
the way to hemwick
I remember
I remember
I remember
the [ __ ] out of my way bro
I'm a goofy goober yeah
foreign
do I have to wear this Crown anymore
this is our man oh good to see you safe
now let's think up something to discuss
just tell me what piques your interest
uh
give unopen summons
ah is that
Sigil of cainhurst
I've heard tell of cainhurst Nobles and
their amusingly pompous invitations
wonderful I thank you profusely
I will depart immediately but first a
token of my gratitude give me something
good brother
wheel Hunter badge what is that
in a bow ah I feel my Master's Hand at
work nah yes praise the good blood raise
it and let us cleanse these tarnished
streets
what did he just [ __ ] say
did you [ __ ] hear that
let us cleanse these tarnished streets
and may the good blood guide your way
these games are connected
you said the word
I'm gonna go to Vicar Amelia like the
the area
he said the Elder ring word
he said the Eldon ring word
from tarnished
Val tarnished
smoldering with the Amiga Flame
power in fear of the night
the hands of the fell Omen shall broke
thee no court
see I could have been the voice actor
pickle Rick thank you for the 10 euros
bro
I really appreciate that thank you very
much
nothing's here oh there is somebody here
hey it's Crow lady yo what up girl
you're not Crow lady
are you
rivers of blood rivers of blood
run
okay we're fine
okay
foreign
Bloodhound step
[ __ ]
what is this
we shot at the exact same time
you can heal
foreign
blood Rapture what are these items I'm
getting guys
okay
okay
was that supposed to be really hard or
something
go speak to Ellen before the room
oh she'll be outside now okay cool
equivalent of rings
okay
got it
do I have those equipped anywhere
oh no
don't you ever listen to your elders
what happened
no matter
was she there earlier
just run right past her
my Glory Days will long ago now oh okay
I know what we're talking about now
I just missed
for you
dude I'm getting so much [ __ ] this too
is Hunter's work
but it Bears no honor
a burden you may choose to carry
the decision is yours alone
oh
my eyes grow heavy
let me rest a while
no you're gonna die I'll be fine just
wait
foreign
no don't die
this is really long
okay
is she gonna die if I leave I don't want
to leave her there I like her
even though she got a little weird
earlier
all right let's go back and do all these
like
Badges and Covenants and stuff
he dies regardless no
why is it in every one of these games
dude every single person I like dies
like don't cap guys Ronnie is a [ __ ] I
know she doesn't die at the end but she
used us and you know it
this doll is better
he's the better doll
hey no Poppy boys
okay
sign of a hunter stamina recovery speed
up I like that
continuous heal near death plus one
Boost Max HP during Co-op
thank you Stan
guys how do I get to the um orphan of
costs am I near that or do I have to be
uh lady Maria first I think
visceral attacks restore 300 HP gimme
gimme gimme gimme
yeah yeah yeah okay
then
boost rally potential increases all
defense types
Arcane defense
she's after Maria okay thank you
I need to go back to cainhurst
that that bet
Max vials held up plus four what does
this mean
all right let's go to let's go to cane
Hurst oh I'd have 24 vials okay gotcha
gotcha gotcha he wouldn't like make my
vials better
right
yeah that's cool
we're good we don't get hit that much
you know what I'm saying
like I'm I'm the Perry guy I've done it
I've done it
ended and grounded this rotten siren
into fleshy pink pout
there you filthy monstrosity this is
literally D from Elden ring
try stirring up trouble in this sorry
state
all mangled and twisted with every
inside on the outside for all the world
to see is this our boy
what the [ __ ] are you holding
oh my God what did you do to her
dude
oh
you is it
look at this thanks to you I've done it
why did y'all make me do this isn't it
wonderful
now Master can be canonized as a true
Martin
[Laughter]
I've done it I have
hahaha
Roar
I Can Save the Queen
ly flesh
arrives eerily
wait
oh my God she's still [ __ ] there
she's still alive
what do I do
offer it to the altar of despair
all right what do I do with this guy do
I just leave him alone
he's Immortal it's the curse of the
Bible it's right right okay
can I kill this guy
I'm gonna leave him alone I'm gonna
leave him I'm only well let's talk to
him again yeah
thank you
I've done it I have
[Laughter]
bro don't trust nobody
okay I know where to go I know where to
go
we got this
oh alternative despair he's about the
same as radar I mean he has a cone on
his head
so he's infected with some rot that
makes him insane yeah
thank you for another 10 euros pickle
Rick I appreciate you dude thanks for
the support
that's a lot thanks
but yeah uh it seems like everybody is a
little little nuts so far
offer flesh to alter
time Flows In Reverse for this scrap of
Flesh
so is she alive
now
yo this game's [ __ ] insane
this game is insane
foreign
it's so much deeper than I originally
thought hey she's good
we're good
what up brother your sister sorry
ma'am
closest
bearer of our blood
I welcome thee
what is thy wish does she not remember
anything
we await thy return
for the honor of cainhurst
so we're just good all right sick she's
not a liver on the chair anymore that's
sick
she doesn't care
wait does she not remember or does she
just legitimately like whatever
it doesn't matter I live through
anything
okay let's go find Alfred because he is
uh
uh near old yarnum right
well
yeah
if you're talking about where the first
time I met him
it's like up the stairs
like by that altar right no no no I know
where to go just Cathedral reward I got
it
I I gotta I got a line
I got a line
so the very first time I met him I know
where that is
when did we first start streaming I
think I streamed this game like two
three weeks ago and then we took a two
week like we did the Elden ring
randomizer
so it's been a while
uh
you know what
y'all die in one hit anyway
leave me be
can I go through here
no there's no ladder piss
yeah I know where I'm going I know where
I'm going I'm just looking around
I'm playing with that one
brother
you aggressive Beast [ __ ] you
you dumb [ __ ] oh boy
oh no
radiance
is that another crown
did he commit scooter ankle
well
is that a good uh Rune guys
he just committed scooter ankle
excellent
I guess
great
leave me alone sir
it's a very good Rune let's go check it
out see what it does
and then we gotta go to lady Maria I'm
assuming right guys
this might have not been the fastest
path
this was definitely not the fastest path
all right it's not too bad
it increases the amount of HP recovered
by Blood vials that [ __ ] is lit
we want that right now right Diggity now
we have not fought Lawrence can we even
fight Lawrence
yup
yup
no Poppy boys
check for new weapons and armor in the
store yes daddy
I can buy a rock for 60.
I haven't used any madman's knowledge at
all
I feel like there's not a lot here
or would it be here
oh
whoa look at that helmet
inhurst armor
yo I want to wear this bro
my Kai does look like Keanu Reeves
whoever said that earlier
yeah dude okay
with the Hunter's hat
oh man
yo
very good looking
I like the knights
yeah we'll do Hunter
look at me dude
yes Gammon awaits you go on good
Good Hunter
your presence some ice she keeps saying
the same stuff
all right what can I sell because I feel
like I have a lot of like unneeded [ __ ]
like wait hold on how many of these
like mad man's knowledges do I have look
at this
will this get me to 60 so I can buy a
rock
no probably not worth okay
what do you guys think lady Maria
still duplicates okay
spirits
I'm not gonna use these I might use the
holy blade
I'm not going to use the Beast cutter
not gonna use this I'm not gonna use
this
um
never gonna get that much blood change
folly
we're just gonna keep the pistol
um
I mean these just don't give me enough
to care
you know what I'm saying
that does
we'll sell it
not gonna wear them doesn't matter
thanks for the crown
no the boom stick
kill the Bots sorry I was focused
kill the Bots dead
excellent
all right whatever let's level
gaming awaits
and all blood echoes
three levels wait
five levels endurance
bigger
alright guys
it's time
farewell goodheart may you
it's time let me buy some blood vials
I can buy 42 bucket let's go
hopefully that carries over probably not
it's time for lady Maria
and then orphan of course
yeah we've been to the old Hunter's
Workshop
I'm gonna need more
we fought her a couple times she's hard
as hell
let's go
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
that's so cool
[Applause]
what
[Music]
that was so badass
[Music]
[Applause]
I have not seen that before where she
grabs you pulls you in and looks you
dead in the eyes and just rips out blood
from your chest that is so
that is so cool
that was an anime moment wow
okay
we're getting it though
weapon at risk huh
[Music]
even though there was a thing in this
game
foreign
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
how do I repair it
been watching him playing bloodborne for
years and never seen that grab it was
cool
he's repaired at the workshop okay let's
go do that
fun fact the doll was modeled after lady
Maria by German after lady Maria left
the Hunter's dream
that is a very cool fact
pickle Rick
thank you for all the super chats that's
awesome
though garamin has like a thing for lady
Maria
okay repair
okay so I obviously need
stuff
I can just sell more stuff
do I just have to repair it once
beautiful
I'm gonna need these sedatives
numbing mist
just don't know what I wanna
fell you know
do we need this ritual blood chat
that's a lot
Maria was his student
it's up to the interpretation of what
their relationship was gotcha okay
I don't think we've killed amygdala yet
either yes we're chalice dungeons
okay I'll hold off
I want that sword
I'm just gonna sell
like I think I only needed like a
thousand
let's do that
so this doll was modeled after Maria
looks a lot nicer here
we're good back to it
back to it
why is there no music here right now
just noticed that
I didn't turn off the music
but music hasn't been playing here you
guys notice that
thank you
I'll keep this additives then Lord for
sure
should I play bloodborne again of course
because I'm at the end of the main game
well we got a lot to do
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that seems like a really good time to do
it right there
[Music]
I wanna hit her but I know she's about
to explode
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
once once you leave this fight you once
you get out of the flow of it it's hard
to get back into it but once you're in
it
oh
but I feel like literally just leaving
and then coming back for like what two
minutes or whatever
I gotta get back into the flow
I mean if you [ __ ] up with her you're
it's not good
[Music]
eternity
another fun fact she was the Prototype
really
I can see that actually
[Music]
pickle Rick again you're freaking nuts
today dude I appreciate you
[Music]
foreign
this stage
[Music]
[Music]
a little bit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
dang it
I had her bro
this is a good fight I like this
pickle Rick thank you man
I like all these facts
yeah we got this I gotta get in the flow
with that last stage I haven't seen it
very much
some attack she loads up
[Music]
foreign
bullets dude
[Music]
[Music]
I'm stuck
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just so you know
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
how does that not Parry her
[Music]
how did that not Parry her
does the is a load up charge up like not
periable
I need more bullets dude
yeah was it a little bit too early
I can make bullets
you just are you talking about like the
blood because I don't want to do that
can I buy bullets is that even a thing
yeah
where was I getting a lot of them
I don't want to do blood bullets
yeah like really good place I can think
of is over here
from the wheelchair dudes
or hold on I'm thinking I've been
thinking of this area to the right
foreign
yeah that loading time was really long
three
there's more up top
dog I do not need this right now bro
don't fall
nothing
all right we should be able to deal with
16 for now
could be good
if you do the run from Victor Emilia in
the church to hammock there's a bunch of
gun guys there that was my bullet Farm I
like that g thank you man for the five
appreciate it
thanks for all the super chats though
guys
are going crazy with it thank you
and that's a good idea
I think you guys were saying hemwick but
I just had this area in my mind like it
was just
what I had in my brain but I'll go there
if I need more we'll go
I want to get back in the flow
oh I could have bought the remaining
four that's true
King nice family
why is it I killed millennia's second
try but I died to lady Maria 56 times
the only explanation is I suck dude how
many times have you guys died in Melania
because I'm assuming everyone here has
played Elden ring probably
and thank you for another five euros
pickle you you're nuts today bro thank
you
I think I might have died
you know what my first stream on YouTube
was
dying to Melania for five hours straight
it must have been a hundred
you actually go watch that stream if you
want
[Music]
damn bro
foreign
[Music]
foreign
I feel like my character fires his gun
really fast
and other times it's like it takes them
forever
[Music]
that's
not at all where I want to be you guys
right there
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
man
that attack is solo insanely fast
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it looks the exactly the same to that
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this stage
this
see that's different
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
all right she's just doing an overhead
attack instead of a snipe now
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh that got me pumped
out of nowhere looked like we were
struggling did it
foreign
TS we can level up one time maybe
where's Lawrence
is Lawrence the fiery Beast
right
Gammon away
very well let me
level skill
farewell good hunt Okay where is he
I think we already have his skull
like what we need
music up for Lawrence
okay
that's voice
done
first DLC area
yeah he's like up the stairs right like
right at the beginning
I have a lot of insight good
uh
together
well I will love you and leave you Jake
gonna go play running simulator 2022 AKA
hell lick loose also congratulations P.S
beware of Lawrence pickle
thank you for all the super chats man
your nuts have fun playing hell at loose
I've heard of that it looks cool
does look like a lot of running though
so thank you have a great rest of your
day appreciate you dude thank you for
the support
talk to Maria and see what she says
where can I talk to her I just killed
her
Good Hunter this may sound strange but
have I somehow changed moments ago from
this place perhaps deep within I sensed
a Liberation from heavy shackles
not not that I know
outpassing strange
huh we'll talk to the doll
right because that's Maria right
you guys said it was modeled
gearman modeled I'm in the way to go on
Good Hunter
your presence somehow soothes
I sense the ancient echoes
they course your veins oh it's because
the dream's on fire she won't say it
damn all right
okay should have been more patient I
guess
let's go do it
so Maria is a part
I mean I guess since she's modeled like
does that doesn't necessarily mean that
she is the doll right like probably not
it's just modeled after her
maybe with her blood
is everything seems to be connected to
blood
so they are connected
they are straight up connected
is it through blood
we make videos on the lore of this game
probably not I mean everyone's already
done the lore of this game don't you
think
I don't need to
everyone's already made it
but
that's a problem
okay Bots are about to die Bots are
about to die I don't know why we're
getting so many today there we go lots
are dead
this guy right here
this is Boss Hard
there's never enough blood warrant
listen I'm not going to be able to add
anything on I don't think
you know I'm just learning all this
stuff you guys are basically telling me
everything so
you know it's not like eldering where we
were all put in the same spot and then
I got
you know initial I played it a lot more
than most people and then made videos on
it and people liked it this like people
got years ahead of me so I don't think
so
foreign
a lot of stuff that we've found today
makes me think that the worlds of Elden
ring and all the other games are
connected in some way
he looks like he's just dying
well
he does a lot of damage
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
whoa
I can't see
bro holy [ __ ]
I like that OST though
no fromsoft would never tell us anything
about anything fear
as from software ever come out and said
anything about the lore of anything
I think so
they never tell us [ __ ]
he'll like mention a few things in
interviews right Miyazaki
would you guys not want to sit down with
Miyazaki and pick his [ __ ] brain
imagine the people that get to
sir
this is a Wendy's I'm gonna need you to
let me go
okay let's try the pellet
I'm assuming fire would be weak to him
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
what the [ __ ]
he's a little crawly boy now
wait I can't even hit him
whoa whoa
whoa
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
excuse me
[Music]
I was straight up like almost full
health and he just boxed my ass
they make me take more damage
seems like I do a lot of damage
well now I gotta go get more [ __ ]
blood vials damn
we can do that pretty quick
I should upgrade
Piano thank you for the dollar I
appreciate that thank you
hope you're doing good
yeah Lawrence is a DLC boss I'm pretty
sure
I should upgrade to plus 10. where is a
um where can I find
a rock I just need a rock and I'm I'm
Plus 10. I don't know where it is though
let me go get some blood vials
I don't think he's uh parryable
maybe somewhere in there but
menses am I already have I already been
there
foreign
yeah it is kind of just the cleric beast
on fire right
oh where I dropped big brain
[Applause]
yeah the Insight vendor it's 60 insight
though that's a lot
foreign
default all of a cage elevator and get
through a window didn't I already do
that
I swear I did
I dropped big brain
[Applause]
usually farmed in chalice dungeons okay
you gotta go to it again and explore
more
okay
do you think it'd be worth it to go to
Plus 10.
I'm down to go now
I mean could I get the 60 insight
I'm at 17.
and I have 33
that's
50.
so no
okay
um so that is mikalash
you said after mikalash
or goes off the middle
you guys aren't crazy with the super
chats today my goodness
thanks for streaming during my sales
meeting LOL not bored now I I'm happy I
can help with that in some way
thank you for the five dollars Master
you guys are great thank you
hope the meeting's going well
isn't there
three chords now you guys are saying
four
[Music]
is it this elevator you're talking about
I miss one of them
I did
does it matter
yeah right here I just walk off
you know unless I just
do that
I don't know why I struggle with this
thing
I have fallen to my death with this
thing so many times
ew ew
dad deadbot I don't even know why they
try I am so ready
for them every time
like they're just annihilated as soon as
they enter the chat
daddy f
come on okay nice
let's [ __ ] go that's like beating a
boss for me right there
okay I don't have to go past these crazy
people again do I
do I have to run that way
now let's go
these things scare me big time
foreign
just absolutely terrifying
can't see me anymore
all right so I hit this
now where do I go
the brain fell
do I gotta go down here
okay I just tried to crouch
can I kill them
oh [ __ ]
stop it
and I'm dead
[Music]
where do I need to go in that area
do I have to drop down again
I don't have to cross the gap
okay
because all we're looking for is a rock
it's something I thought I'd never say
to myself
I'm fine
I'm fine
you know there are some days like today
where I think you guys should like maybe
I should have a webcam on
because you should just see my face
scowling
if that's even a right word
said blue Elixir makes it harder for
them to see me
foreign
oh you know because I'm [ __ ]
invisible
I don't think they could have made these
guys creepier like this is it this is as
creepy as it gets to me it's just
[ __ ] creepy
straight up no cap
it's a horror game I'm playing a horror
game
currently what I'm playing
okay another one
that's there this is a Wendy's stop
how did you see me
you guys said there's a door in here but
I don't see it
like over here
into the room
do the right
[ __ ]
behind me
I went through that door
what
that's where I came in
this isn't where I entered
oh my God
thank you
ignore me
ignore me
for eight one's wisdom everywhere dude I
could probably afford it now
I don't even need the Rock
damn that guy got [ __ ] up
look at that man
in this scene what's over here
oh this is me that's his boss room
interesting
I think I literally can't afford it now
yeah it's 60 insight and I think I can
afford it
he said drop down and to the right
okay clearly not there holy [ __ ]
that Moon's getting close
you all want me to go down there bro
okay
I don't like it here
but I like that
but I like that where does that go
did we test it
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
you know what I don't even care come on
[ __ ]
you think I'm scared of you anymore punk
ass
punk ass
I think I'm scared of you [ __ ]
get out here with that missed ass
[ __ ]
come here
I think I'm scared of you
oh gas
get out of here
oh
you're dumb ass out of here
thanks for the sedatives
little [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
it's crazy as I feel like I get better
as I play
did you go talk to the big brain
did I miss it
this is where the big brain was the
shaft is where it is now okay
I have not talked to the big brain
should I talk to the big brain
you're going straight for the brain
okay here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
go pee I'm gonna go let out the dogs and
then we'll be back and we'll continue
do you guys have a Mimi song request for
while I'm gone
one that will not get this copyrighted
potentially
copyright is bad everyone go take a
bathroom break and or get a snack
but we will be right back
um I'm trying to think of a meme song
any osc from bloodborne okay
spooky scary skeletons you got it that's
the first good one
is this uh is this copyrighted
there's no [ __ ] shot right
thank you
there's just no way it's copyrighted
right
spooky scary skeletons go dripping down
your spine okay I'm not gonna do that
I'm just gonna play uh
bloodborne
OST
there you go guys
I'll be right back
BRB
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay we're back
[Music]
huh
dude I did a leg workout yesterday I
can't walk
I'm just slower at everything
[Music]
okay good [ __ ]
all right where are we going
Jake made a stinky I didn't go poop I
just peed and then I had to let the dogs
outside and they're slow
to meet brain I'll go this way to meet
brain
oh there's tons of fan art for this game
it's up here
a lot of nada
yeah yeah we'll upgrade we'll upgrade
obviously for sure
is it this elevator right here yeah we
killed Maria
is it this elevator
contact gesture
oh no
foreign
attack me
I'm just kind of scared of him
you think they'll make a bloodborne 2 or
a remaster
I think they'll just remaster it I don't
think they'll make a bloodborne too
personally
it'll be like a sakuro
you're always upset of course
be barking at him
probably someone at the door
someone delivering a package is it this
thing
there you go
they're trying to push me out
Joy quit barking
where am I going dude
Joy
thank you
um
what's going on here
foreign
time to make contact
just walk out
you guys see that [ __ ]
okay
I don't have a torch
make contact
its eyes are so big it reminds me of
Godwin
thank you
whoa that's sick
should I just leave him alone
hello
I can I can spank them
foreign
[Music]
foreign
blood that is so [ __ ] cool
this game man is unbelievable
unbelievable
he tried to make a great one with that
guy
nope you do a lot of damage [ __ ] that
see you later
foreign
okay
wait isn't there one right over here
right across the way
well let's go upgrade
we'll kill Lawrence and then we'll go
for amygdala however you say his name
no I have not stephanus
a hunter must hunt
hi Brandon
Hunter
my homies at the shop get distracted
with the Stream
that is good
y'all are homies thank you boys
um hi booted how are you
what's upgrade plus 10. let's go
didn't have to use all our insight to do
it too
[Music]
nice weapon master
did I see what we can get our holy Moon
blade up to we actually need 14.
it don't matter
okay
let's go and fight Lawrence
I am also magnificent booted
thank you for asking
you miss mommy Crow mommy Crow is dead
you think there's a reason they like
using coats and capes I think it's it's
cold out
and it looks cool
is there a um
like if I throw this pungent cocktail
will Lawrence go for it
I don't think I want to use the uh Beast
blood pellet
so that could actually help is he weak
to fire I really doubt it
okie dokie
is it like Elden ring where Moog
is weak to blood somehow
bolt helps a little okay if we if we
struggle here we will uh we'll go get it
I'm just gonna hit him
there's a summon for this fight
could make the fight trivial and you're
not getting the proper experience
if you use a summy
I don't think it's a viable playthrough
if you if you used a summing
God
testing pungent cocktail
he did not give a [ __ ]
prayers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
not going well guys
[Music]
jumped
[Applause]
this is
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
nice let's go nice
[Music]
GG I went full Focus mode there that
music is great holy crap that music is
good
full Focus
is there more to the song
foreign
to it
I listened to the worst half
let's see
uh Lawrence
bloodborne
OST
the first vicar the car
[Music]
thank you
I mean this
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
is that pretty much the whole thing
yeah it is nice dude
that might be
man dude gearman's theme though
that's really good that's definitely in
my top three
that's in the top three a thousand
percent
you got those lyrics memorized that's
impressive
uh I played a bit of haul and I I
haven't finished it though
very well let me
one level guys
has um has bloodborne won any awards
did It win any awards you find your
worth in the waking because it lost to
um Witcher 3 for game of the year right
let me buy some blood vials and other
stuff too
because we gotta go
where where's amygdala at how do I fight
that guy
let's just buy one
of those
as many as I can carry
a bit about those first
nightmare Frontier
I mean I didn't win game of the year
right
I thought um
Witcher 3 did
it didn't win best music award
right
now
buy some fire paper
give me like I
because I have so many
he won zero Awards
that
is nuts to me
nightmare Frontier
foreign
I mean I would say this game
you know why I bet it didn't win game of
the year in 2015. it was only on
Playstation you could play Witcher on
any anything I'm pretty sure
that's got to be the only reason
not enough people played it
foreign
Bloodstone sergeant LOL
I gotta write
yeah we want to get there
how do I get there
I gotta go down there
[Applause]
snarl
yep
I think it's a [ __ ] shame that this
game can't be played by everybody
oh I gotta activate a lift I
know that's right I remember this area a
little bit
yeah isn't there a skip there I think
you're right on that one
this Lantern is very suspicious what the
heck
before Elden ring Sakura was the highest
selling Souls game
and it only sold 5 million copies since
release Alden ring is sitting at 16
million
I mean imagine if bloodborne especially
now that everyone's played Elden ring I
think more people would want
as we play bloodborne
you know what I mean
Man Hunter you're a [ __ ] Noob bro
you're a noob
oh not you though
imagine not having a plus 10 weapon
I pet my dog all day every day because
of you guys not any other reason
it's the highest rated Souls game
bloodborne
yeah
I'm definitely overpowered
for sure
that can stop anytime I don't like that
is the elevator over here
I bought a PS4 to play bloodborne
maybe that's their thought process is
like we'll sell more PlayStation 4s
if we keep bloodborne
on PlayStation
it could be their thought process maybe
this is not leading where I want I think
yep imagine not hitting the like button
could be me
I'm going back this is not what I wanted
whatever we'll get poisoned again
yep I would say it's a shame that this
game isn't uh on Xbox
on uh play on PC on everything
maybe except switch I don't know how
you'd play this game on switch but
they should absolutely Port it I'm
I'm you know I think this game would
sell incredibly well
if it was ported
that's how big rock you have there sir
very nicer rock you have
oh there's more excellent
all right that area [ __ ] sucks ass
are those ships
just like Elden ring
there there are so many references in
this game to eldering dude so many no
actually you can't be that strong
bro why is this
that ain't Fair
that ain't Fair bruh
life ain't Fair
yeah frenzy seems to build no matter
what I do
kind of [ __ ] mate
Alden ring will win game of the year I
think it really depends on how well
Ragnarok goes
foreign
God of War is going to have a bit of an
advantage
in its uh release window
when it comes to Game of the Year
because now the honeymoon phase of Elden
ring is over
and people are going to be thinking more
about God of War when it comes up
unless Eldon ring comes out with DLC
and obviously God of War doesn't flop
which it won't it'll be a good game
it'll win
and we got our shortcut excellent
excellent
we really out here
getting Fancy with it
dude that looks awesome
I'm good Daniel how are you
that's not your hand
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I can't see man
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Pro Gamer
bro gamer
you just spank the legs dude
you see the legs you hit the legs you
know what I'm saying
you see legs hit legs
thank you Hunter
I love the doll it's just like standing
in front of the fire just cracks me up
man
like hey everything's fine
everything's fine
this is fine
Gammon away
I know
garman's been awaiting me for quite a
while you could say
quite a while
okay let's do this
get those
get those
why not [ __ ] it
ladies and gentlemen I think it's orphan
time
or at least the area where the orphan is
Jay rodley
welcome to the tarnish dude welcome to
the agency thanks for becoming a member
I really appreciate it
thank you very much welcome enjoy the
fun emotes that you can use to make fun
of me
enjoy it man thank you very much good to
have you
okay
it's orphan time
we'll see what we need once we get to uh
to the orphan but for now let's just get
there
I believe we have the orphan
and then gearman correct
if we want to do the Chalice dungeons we
can
foreign
ER I paid a sub to Bro not gonna lie
that's good
that's good to hear I'm glad you like it
here I guess
the doll take your time dear Hunter the
cabin is on fire but apparently the
Flames do not burn it
thank you Angel
I don't know what is that currency
what's MX
but it's like two dollars and fifty
cents thank you man I appreciate it
Dark Souls 3 has way better bosses
I really really enjoy Dark Souls 3 like
a lot hold up
I thought that said Celestial do and I
was about to stop the stream to make a
lore video on how these games are
compared to Alden ring
it almost said Celestial do and I was
gonna be like excuse me
foreign
thank you rodley
I'm glad
thank you for watching
oh [ __ ]
so we're down here
I see
oh man
is that a boat
tournament for the wrenches
by the rat of mother cause
poor wasn't child
please
is this guy madshill
it's own meant for the wrenches
lay the curse of blood upon them
and their children
and their children's children
forevermore each wretched birth
who's Batman challenge each child
into a lifetime of misery
the guy seems overly negative don't you
think
boss is Batman where is he Batman
that's just very negative
so that guy uh doesn't look good
it's like I can drop that down as a
shortcut later
that was creepy
wait where
I swear I'm blind
I am wow okay you can't you gotta admit
that blends in
that blends in
my drip is unparalleled I think
bloodborne's gotta have like the best
armor
no like it's not even armor but it's
just like for fashion mostly which I
think is like
I prefer that over just having like
really strong looking armor
okay you all need to chill
on the show
oh lock on
[Music]
foreign
don't worry about me guys
okay Reichard Reichard Reichard chill
hello
are you nice
blood gem master
I like getting achievements
okay
no no no no no no no no no no
what
what is that
it's a whale
foreign
hello
you're just like blind from all this
beautiful yes that's why I'm just you
know everything's so pretty
that I'm blind to that hello we're
getting a lot of Subs right now
bam thanks
I guess it's a good time to say guys
we are less than 5 000 Subs away from
100K laps in the chat
sub count is kind of arbitrary but
still cool to accomplish something like
that so we'll give it a shot
we'll go for it
taken a while
it's all good
we'll get there when we get there
no not again
he has a pitchfork
do I want to be down here guys like I
don't know how I feel nope
laughs
go go go go go go go [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
nope nope nope nope nope
I'm I'm good honestly I'm good without
dealing with that
foreign
we want to we'll come back
not that arbitrary Beauty to 14 years
getting a thousand jumping through oops
is hard as [ __ ]
okay we really need to make dogs harder
did we really need to do that probably
not
no like
what I mean by arbitrary is more like
you know
it
you know what you're right it is cool
let's get there we're almost there
we're almost there
I have no bullets
we stopped screaming at me
no
all y'all need to stop it
no I don't need to use that birds it's
okay
bye
guys this place sucks
like this is awful
[Music]
I bought
holy [ __ ]
foreign
how do you fight this thing
you you fight it by running away
we roll in oh yeah I'm just straight up
not fighting that thing no thanks
what am I hearing right now
where's the lamp
I missed one
oh I hear it it's in here
I don't know who made that noise but
[ __ ] chillax all right
yo what up metal
how hot that I join and eat on the spot
yo what are you talking about
what are you talking about
you cut it out right now
right what'd you say
earlier hold on you said
um
Hey Jake how would you feel about a
members only monthly or bi-weekly q a
would you guys want a q a
you guys know you can ask me anything at
any point right
okay I can't open the door
like I answer questions
but that sounds cool
what's his shoe size shoe size I wear a
ten and a half
how big is your you didn't finish the
question I don't know what you're
talking about
trying to incentivize more members I
don't think that would do that
I want people to become members if they
want to
and it like only if they want to support
the channel
other than that
they don't have to
favorite cereal
Cinnamon Toast Crunch and that's the
only answer
oh this bridge is nuts hello so
let me go ahead and leave you to that
my guy
good good good
if I got bit on the pp by a snake would
you suck the venom out
no I wouldn't
[ __ ] you
I lift like three four times a week
I would like to increase that because
that's not enough
when I move into my apartment in
November I'll have like a really nice
home gym that I'm actually really
excited about
what shampoo do you use Dr Squatch I
also use Dr Squatch nope
worst enemy in any game you've ever
played
uh revenants eldering
where am I going right now
okay I'll walk through over there
it's just another rickety-ass Bridge
how did you get joy I adopted her
nah that's a bait
I adopted her from a local shelter
right when she had 11 puppies
right after she had 11 puppies
tried to [ __ ] bait me bro what's your
favorite Chinese food orange chicken
fried rice
pretty [ __ ] basic
pretty [ __ ] good you ask me
like
rollables
what enemy is bald wraith and Apex
actually worst enemy is ball great
gotcha
how many fingers do you have 10
guys am I going the right direction
there he is quite confusing
okay I don't think I have any throwables
oh I have eight fingers and two thumbs
pebble's gonna break that
[ __ ] bro
foreign
[Applause]
favorite fast food
this is gonna piss a lot of people off
McDonald's
I listen to all types of music except
for country
I might say like
I'm listening to a lot of tool and Foo
Fighters right now so like kind of rock
type stuff
nope
he just like blocked me by doing nothing
like this sometimes dude I like getting
a Big Mac
Big Macs are good they are
a little Double Quarter Pounder action
it's [ __ ] good
it's my favorite
this guy's really got out for me huh
where I'm going guys so
I'll pile into your double quarter let's
[ __ ] go dude
you're like on
on Avenue bolts
I don't like this at all
can I even hit him
yeah look at that that's what happens
every time I try to hit him what the
[ __ ]
iced coffee and nuggies that's what I'm
[ __ ] talking about bro
it's honestly what I like to hear
go away
search the body
am I about to fall off somewhere here
that looks like death typical water
death
can you yodel
ing
does that answer your question
oh I can go that way
wait there's no um
I think I go over here
energy drinks are terrible for you and I
don't recommend drinking them so I don't
drink them
more video on why we can't swim because
Miyazaki can't swim
so in his games if he can't swim nobody
can there you go
there's your lore
get Lord
okay ask me how often I get McDonald's
you're gonna say says the guy who eats
McDonald's
ask me how often
where do I go
I get McDonald's maybe once a month
I need to get there so I need to go
there
which is up this ladder
leave me alone people
you're bad at the game you're bad at the
game
sorry just need to think that one out
ignore the Spears in my body
you ever seen me
it's not a problem
okay
if you were going to drink
an energy drink I would recommend gamer
sups
guys this is where I came from
right
and Siri is confusing
it's like an actual town that I'm
exploring
go away go away
back off [ __ ]
foreign
no clue how I'm alive right now
we're not sponsored by gamer Subs
apparently
I like can't even hit this guy which is
why I'm not even fighting him
dude I'm all the way back where I came
from how is this possible
what incarnation
foreign
yeah that worked really well I did
exactly what you said
oh wait no you didn't
why doing wrong here guys
I gotta jump to that roof Maybe
ha ha
I at this point I would like your
guidance I don't know where I'm going I
don't see a direction on where to go
I mean I don't know what you guys mean
by straight from the main Bridge
because I don't see it
foreign
reset it for me anyway
all the bridges I mean maybe I just
didn't see another one
thank you
can I just go this way no
Simon
can't talk
oh hello
how are you
afraid I've made a bunch of things
near the Bell now
the beast's height assassin
he's after me
again
it never ends
this Village is the true Secret
Testament to the old sins
feeds this Hunter's nightmare that would
be nice Samantha please
bring to an end the horror
so our forefathers sin
we Hunters cannot bear their weight
forever
Hill orphan of costs kill gearman
in stream that's the goal of Misfit it
just isn't fair
oh
Simon's a bow blade Underground
cell inner chamber key this one
damn
Underground
rip Simon
yes use chords before Garmin obviously
oh it's the door next to the Ludwig got
it oh I could have just ran literally
straight right there huh
that's cool
that's cool yep didn't see this at all
okay that's just you know lightning I'd
like that for me
[ __ ] you
bullets
more bullet vials more blood vials
yes twin blades are the best weapon in
Dark Souls 3 absolutely
are you kidding my dick right now bro
are you kidding my dick
my back
I got stun locked and died no cap
damn
get annihilated Jake honestly you suck
all right guys
oh Trey if you're still in chat
um
this train was like trying to come up
with something to
incentivize people to become members
I would say the only way to do that
would be have membership goals like if
we hit a certain amount of members then
I'll do something special that chat
wants me to do
that's what I did on Twitch and we got
to like 2500 Subs on there
at one point
more bullets more
huh
what door did that open excellent
I love that for us
[ __ ] it
I mean when I play Dark Souls 3 Daniel
I'm definitely gonna play with the twin
blades a thousand percent you
just one more shortcut
oh I don't like it in here at all
this is scary
all right Chad give me give me a
membership goal
if we hit a certain amount of members
what should I do
within reason
are you kidding go away you're awful
[ __ ] guy shows up whenever he wants
to man
that killed me huh okay
you want me to dress up as Melania
a millennia cosplay
what would I get her helmet
I know you can get those
what's up Dragonite
say that there is something fishy on the
horizon yes indeed
this didn't really help
are you like what is this I get stun
locked and I instantly die
you know what a cosplay is is where I
dress up I would dress up as millennia
we could do like if we get to I don't
know how many members would be this goal
but like I could try and beat Melania at
plus seven New Game Plus dressed up as
Millennia that'd be funny
oh pause play
so you want me to be naked
for that cosplay
as the orphan
Makey Jakey
foreign
[Music]
we're going down the hole boys
not worth
maybe that was really good I don't know
way down here
melania's helmet does look sick
I see it
ah
oh this is it isn't it I remember seeing
this
when I watched gameplay of this
yup
it's time
I wish it was gearman to be honest
let's do this thing
we already got our weapon to Plus 10.
this is gonna [ __ ] suck isn't it
foreign
nice
nice
my guy's crying
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
yep
uh-huh
yep
yep
okay
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
oh you can throw too got it okay
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
toss
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
nice to lay on the throw there [ __ ]
I can hit him like once
[Music]
foreign
that's terrifying
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
guys uh
holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] it give me it all
where where was it
is it here
I'm about to tell you if melania's or if
orphan's harder than Melania
hey yeah you know maybe sometimes I
should have the camera on because like
you should see my face like my eyes are
like straight open my mouth is to the
floor like I'm like dude
I felt like I was doing so well there
and then he was like no you're not
foreign
you thought
he was like you had a great game I'm
like what do you mean I had a great game
like hey man you had you had a great
game and it's not over yet I'm like what
why did I go down here oh did I just
[ __ ] myself yeah I did see how off I am
right now
wait no I didn't no it's that way see
I'm I am way off my rocker right now
guys
I am all over the place
that really got me
okay I'm gonna get over it and we're
gonna be fine
we're gonna be fine
thank you
[Applause]
we're gonna be we're gonna be fine
mm-hmm
it's gonna be fine
we're fine
I got this
I got this man Pro Gamer
what I'm getting from this fight so far
is that I have to be patient I have to
that's what I'm getting out of this just
initially
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
I know I'm like 10 minutes into this
this guy's harder than Melania
going the wrong way
wrong way yet again
you guys think a deck he's watching me
right now
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
look how much damage that's doing
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
how do you time that right
[Music]
a little earlier
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you see those Dodges though
see those Dodges pretty good
learned a little bit more
doing good
oh I'm gonna have to be dead quiet guys
focus on this
the Perry timing's really hard
can you parry his second stage because I
feel like I hit a couple shots and it
didn't work
but maybe I just missed the timing
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
that killed me that attacked us an
insane amount of damage
and I keep thinking I can Dodge in but
it like he holds it all the way into
himself and it still hits me for all the
damage
I need to like just back up when he does
that
when he does that like he extends it out
a couple of times in front of him
that was a lot of damage for sure
I'm learning the Parry times
actually doing pretty good
easily the hardest boss in the game
though
easily
[Music]
does that not Harry
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
why was he he was just throwing all that
[ __ ] for like a minute and a half
straight
what was that
well you know I expect it maybe once or
twice in a row he did it like five six
times in a row
where he jumps up in the [ __ ] air and
throws all his placenta around and
explodes all over the place over and
over and over again
I mean man
huh
I gotta go farm I don't have enough [ __ ]
now
he's throwing a tantrum
pretty much I mean [ __ ]
is Ludwig's area just the best place to
farm
or vials and stuff
can I whip the cape that's kind of cool
his pattern is random I mean I'm pretty
sure he did one attack like six times in
a row
and like the whole time I'm watching him
do it and honestly like I was dodging
most of it and I'm all I'm thinking to
myself is
is he gonna stop
and they no he didn't
so he's just like quite literally doing
whatever he wants in that stage huh
I don't know what [ __ ] [ __ ] is what are
you guys talking about it looks like [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh wait
I'll let the outer Gods guide me I'm
very chill I'm chilled out man I love
the fight
like it here's the big difference
between like difficulty
I think the only reason Melania is
difficult is because of waterfowl that's
the only way she's difficult it makes it
[ __ ] and I don't like the fight
because of it whereas orphan of costs I
actually like I'm enjoying myself
learning how hard this is you know like
based on how hard it is I'm enjoying
learning the process
and trying to not bait out attacks but
like understand which ones I can Dodge
in and away and parry and stuff like
that where Melania I'm running in and
out to make her do waterfowl that's all
I'm doing
so
so there's your big difference there
and she can heal yeah
I think it's waterfowl
imagine you could like Parry her
waterfowl that'd be sick imagine if you
could yeah Harry
okay so one of these dudes
which which one
yeah I think my I think my gems are as
good as they can be nandez but let me
check them again real quick
it's water flow
it's definitely not
right
oh this isn't the right one
it's waterfowl
I'm not even saying waterfall waterfowl
yeah that's the best one we got
yep
good
the move is called [ __ ]
okay which one am I going to
Dallas ritual into the glyph hum [ __ ]
and enter the dungeon
that ain't it
that ain't come [ __ ]
that ain't come [ __ ]
all these are the same
why are you guys calling it what it's
called
I need blood Echoes to do this
excuse me
okay
um
does it matter which one I do here
huh
foreign
never done this before
let me go to the next one
it's the only one I saw
what
what's happening
why would I go back
dude why am I what
foreign
guys
there's people on uh twitch that stream
for like 14 hours a day
five hours
searched by glyph now in inter humpback
oh that's the one [ __ ]
I don't know what I'm doing I don't know
what this is I've never done it
a tip he said it didn't matter which one
me
man
24-hour stream on Twitch I did one
24-hour stream on Twitch and I'll never
do it again
I already used my blood echoes
good to hear nandas
I am offline
oh motherf God dang it
it doesn't matter
um
all right I think of what I want to do
where I want to go what I want to see
man
[ __ ] it
I need to keep in the flow of this fight
we might have to do this again tomorrow
like tomorrow will just be
beating cause and beating gearman
okay I don't I don't know what that is
we're gonna be fine
yeah I'll have to change the title
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's what happens when I get out of a
fight
that's what kind of sucks is I wish I
didn't have to go like Farm stuff
and I could just keep trying over and
over again
I gotta like stay in it or that happens
at least I didn't use anything
you know how hard that is to do Brian
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
well stage one I don't think I could
have done better
I think I parried him like five times
I'm not role play Walking I'm just
walking into a position where I he's
gonna do something it looks like I'm
role play Walking but if I like don't
just like run around then I can like
bait out certain like him to jump or do
something that I can Parry I walk on
purpose so I'm not just like this
but stage one was perfect
did you guys say they they nerfed
Melania is that what you guys are
talking about
I definitely need more bullets where's a
I'm I'm forgetting a good place to farm
bullets again you guys told me a good
spot and I don't remember where it is
it's uh
let's go back
research Hall
I mean I don't want Souls I want
Virgo's Loft middle
foreign
no I'm I need bullets and blood vials
Echo I just want bullets I don't have
bullets
guys give me a [ __ ] Pebbles dog
buying blood Echoes makes no sense
have a good one fiction
I don't think that's the place we want
to be
I don't never mind
I can get like five at a time just by
killing one person that's what I'm
trying to say
foreign
it was
Ford
I remember now
I remember
I have not put anything in storage
can I buy blood vials with insight
and a lot of that
foreign
yeah I know what you're talking about
with Margo's middle now
I'm good on vials though I'm gonna go to
where I know there were bullets
oh they Auto go to storage okay I should
check that then
foreign
enough to feel comfy but yeah I'll check
it
I feel like Auto going here never mind
a bunch of shooty guys out here
there's also a lot of [ __ ] dogs
then I can buy more
okay
[Music]
if okay if bloodborne was set in America
bullets wouldn't be an issue
you're not wrong
I live in America and I've never shot a
gun in my life
thank you
they are scary I don't like them
I want any kind of literally any
DLC for Elden ring would be cool
I'll take anything
no I know I just don't like guns I know
people kill people and guns also kill
people
people can use those weapons to kill
people I don't want that argument
doesn't make sense to me but they each
their own
hi beep how are you
yes more Elden ring would be great
however they made the game
absurdly large
already
so imagine them they're like man really
they want [ __ ] more really okay you
know what I mean
okay I probably do have a lot in storage
you're right
yeah we're gonna have to probably do
another stream but we'll see I'll try to
get this done
for now
I know those okay
let's try again
yep there's another beep you're not the
only beep
I'm doing good thank you for asking
we're trying to get this game done but
I'm I'm going up against the hardest
boss in
the game
and I have to get more [ __ ]
now we're gonna go try again
I become a hunter Madness
I believe we did do elin's Quest aliens
Quest however you say your name
all right let's try this again
I'm really enjoying this fight a lot
like it's not it's not uh annoying to
fight at all
this is extremely difficult obviously
I haven't been able to Parry him in
phase two yet
phase one I got
so right there I just walked huh
[Applause]
[Applause]
I got caught in a combo
I was literally staggered that entire
time and couldn't do anything
foreign
yeah I mean if I can Parry in second
stage I don't know how that's greedy
when I couldn't move
I wasn't doing anything I just got hit
one time and then it was
stuck
I forget what I was saying though
yeah wood Beast pellets work on this guy
I might try it for first phase
also use fire
[Music]
I can't move
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
that is really weird
at the end of that hits me
the hitbox lingers forever
[Applause]
oh
underhand
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
does he usually jump twice
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
everything
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that hurts man I was getting it though
[ __ ] I I tried to dodge at the end his
fourth bang on the ground hit me and
staggered me so long that the last hit
the last one he goes for there just
demolished me and I couldn't [ __ ]
move dude
the staggers this guy does where I'm
like I can't move
where I'm like mashing Dodge to just get
the [ __ ] out of there
I still need to check my storage because
I do think I have extra stuff there
pickle Rick's back
[Music]
together
the order of everyetta is
in the house once again welcome back sir
I might try that we'll see I think I
almost got it though thank you Dan
really appreciate it
I think I got this though
[Music]
[Applause]
I just did it a little bit too late that
sucks
what's
[Applause]
I didn't think I got it damn I thought I
did it too early
[Music]
[ __ ]
do not mean to jump there
foreign
[Music]
that's what I want
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hitbox is so strange
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
if you if you [ __ ] up on this guy you
die
[ __ ]
hmm
okay
more blood vials obviously
do that
yeah I just didn't know like am I can I
tell where the Lightning's gonna come
down
because it just seemed to hit me
directly in the face
do I have can I see like what I have
I see okay so it just automatically goes
in my [ __ ] got it
40 each
I'm not gonna use these
they're just
only afford five really okay
um
wait can I
hold on
it strikes out of the mother of course
I mean that hit me in the middle of the
water
what
it's diamonds bably am I going to want
to use this probably not
we sold all the other ones too [ __ ] it
let's go
I just want to keep getting back into
the fight because I think I am actually
really close to beating him
for real for real
I already sold gas coins Garb I'm pretty
sure
I think so
foreign
gotcha I might do that
oh my God this is hard let's go
[Music]
foreign
what
my bullet just went screaming past his
forehead
foreign
yeah I think you're right
do it again
it doesn't do a little more
explain to me how that's not a parry and
I try to walk
yeah a lot of people have been asking me
to make bloodborne lore or other game
lore and I'm like I mean it's been done
to death guys there's like nothing more
I could possibly say I don't think
this game's been out for how long seven
years
it's a long time
the amount of times you've visceraled
him
is that bad
my voice is cool I don't think that
automatically means I should make lore
on something
I'm getting a phone call
a phone call is gonna have to wait
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah that definitely does a little bit
more I think with even out the uh
the
pellet
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
not working
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
I can't even tell where I am
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
dude [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
it's a really odd attack
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I thought I had a second more
I thought I had one more second man I
really did
I was gonna Dodge to the side
and everything was gonna be
thick
and then I died
I mean I am in the ocean
it's a different bot every time rudley
it looks the same but it's not
[Applause]
he just he actually took my body and
dragged me to the side
you see that when I dodged back and he's
like running
his body carried me over
and then comboed me so stick
just I didn't use anything
you can Parry both phases by the way
I mean I haven't been able to find uh
a spot to carry in stage two yet
it trivializes lightning I mean I'm in
the ocean
when he's doing the lightning
and
I guess I need to run further away
I'm not tilted at all
it's fine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fun fact those hunters in the nightmare
are the ones who reap the fishing
Village and killed costs they were
punished by students
[Music]
that sounds interesting
I want to know how that hit me I really
do
thank you Rick
you're the man
it's not doing attacks that I wanted so
[Music]
unfortunately
he is not nice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this this [ __ ] twig of a tree just
killed me
this twig of a tree dude
I died to a twig
man
I can do it without even healing this
much
I'm gonna keep going
please don't use that word horror
I got twigged
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
to get health back
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
he is going off
foreign
[Applause]
actually
hold on a sec
oh he usually gives vials
he gives bullets
Jared
I want to see you pop off this time bro
dude I'm always trying to pop off
the five dollars I appreciate it
we've had so many super chats today it's
actually unreal thank you guys
thank you thank you
I know I should Farm but I'm trying to
figure something out right now
[Applause]
he reacts to distance
[Applause]
[Music]
that's really annoying
okay I'll go far
I'm not gonna do the calm dungeon
we I'm not online I can't
God
holy [ __ ] this boss is insane
it's just the fact that he kills me so
quickly
okay well I tried to do it earlier and
nothing happened so with the dungeons
he gave me two I'll take it
this boss is 100 harder than Melania
for sure
the only I believe the only two bosses
we have left is cause and gearman
and then the moon presence
if we want to do that
which we have all the umbilical cords
for so yeah we're doing it
might have to come back tomorrow
because I think I gotta leave but I'm
not entirely sure yet
[ __ ] man
foreign
I mean we've almost killed him how many
times like twice
okay real attempt here
I was trying to figure something out and
it's just getting worse so that ain't
gonna work hi Joy how are you
hi honey how are you
have you decided to come say hi
what's up Bubba snoot
it's your Bubba schneuters it's the JoJo
beans
she's gonna lay on the floor right there
that's a good girl
that's so good you can go lay on the bed
if you want you don't gotta lay on the
floor
Joy is a mix of a German Shepherd
and a golden retriever
[Music]
very cute
hi JoJo
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign that's unfortunate
for help
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
how does running into the ocean
trivialize that at all I don't get it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
yep I use way more vials than I wanted
to there obviously
oh let me go here
I think I've hired more there I had a
really good shot
okay this guy's not consistent with
giving anything so let's get the [ __ ]
out of here I'm just gonna do the Ludwig
one
seems to be the best
this really is an October game huh it
really is
all right you guys gonna be here for the
sponsored stream tomorrow or no
I gotta do a one hour segment of the
stream tomorrow we'll be sponsored
okay where am I going where am I going
this way
I bet you guys can guess what it is
it'd be around the same time that I
usually stream
not free t-shirts I don't think so
why did I go here [ __ ] my brain is all
over the place man
no I will not be dressed as Melania
that's a different thing
that's a membership goal
it's the wrong one man
[ __ ]
my brain
is fried
I should probably stop but I won't do
Penny image
I mean we'll see we'll see
I don't know what time probably around
like 10 to noon CST
yes the roof is on fire it has been on
fire my
God this one
my God
yeah Lawrence was
fairly easy
I'm pretty sure I can just tell you guys
what the sponsored stream is
but it'll be a one hour segment of the
Stream
so like we'll be doing this tomorrow and
then for one hour we gotta go do a
sponsored thing and then we'll get back
on this after we do that
which I've never done a sponsored stream
before so
a bearer
with me
[ __ ] mate oh my God I can't even do
anything anymore
Holgate
hmm
one hour toothbrush
listen
what's the most popular
stream sponsor thing you've ever ever
seen
I don't know if popular is the right
word
valorant
huh
all right you guys got it it's rage
Shadow Legends
I have personally never played it and
we're gonna check it out for one hour
tomorrow
it's on PC now
PC and mobile
I mean we'll definitely have a good time
with it that's absolutely
raid is lame I've never played it we're
gonna play it tomorrow
see that's what I think Garrett I think
when I play it I make it fun
you're actually playing raid right now
you guys if you've played raid you gotta
like tell me how to do [ __ ]
kinda like you do with these streams
thank you
that's pretty much how our streams go
anyway you guys like tell me what to do
yeah
we're gonna check it out tomorrow I'm
gonna I'm gonna have fun with it and
then uh we're gonna finish bloodborne
obviously too
because I don't think it's happening
today guys I really don't if if we don't
get it in this
this try are these few attempts here
with the vials that I have we're gonna
go again tomorrow
foreign
I have no idea if it's pay to win or not
we're basically reenacting Ratatouille I
mean you guys try to do that you're like
Jake turn left go back turn around
be the most epic thing in the world if I
gave you guys like chat like if you
chatted left my character would run left
and you tried to beat bloodborne like
that
okay well I'm gonna check it out
tomorrow
I'm gonna have fun
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
he's like getting inside the Rock
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
help that gave me
[Applause]
I dodged into it that's excellent
that was so risky not to this heel dude
that gives me full health back when I do
that holy [ __ ]
I like it
it felt bad
through
yeah some of his moves are just like
he'll just like
baby
just out of nowhere and just be like
whoop there you go I'm like oh okay
there was no tell on that one my guy but
okay
look how every time I die sailor goes
greed
I think you just like that word
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
that one right there
I think was readable it it was an
instantaneous attack
nuts
nuts nuts nuts nuts nuts
get me back in there
faster loading times are ass
with this game on PC I would have been
at orphan again already
he is also I'm learning not consistent
at all
with where I stand and the attacks that
he does
he pretty much does whatever the [ __ ] he
wants
foreign
[Music]
what is that
okay
I'm healing once and getting a visceral
no I'm not
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I tried to jump
[Music]
I feel like the Bots are like they know
when I'm at a point where I can't look
and then they start spamming
I tried to jump the lightning like this
I can dodge through it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
stopped his [ __ ] movement
these trees dude
foreign
are you kidding what
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he threw that
directly in my face in one shot me
he threw that entire thing in my mouth
and killed me
I'm getting five more
and I'm trying one more time
who was patronizing you what
yeah I know he throws six of those I
think all of them I was so close to his
body that I think all of them hit me
all of them at once
yeah it's a shotgun placenta
yep
I think this will be a tomorrow thing
for sure
because this is absolutely [ __ ]
bonkers
[Applause]
that is a good brand name
shotgun placenta that's like a nice
it's a nice like band name
shotgun placenta
that's cool okay
this is uh definitely not a lot of vials
not a lot of bullets
not a lot of a lot not a lot of anything
but
let's give it a try
you never know
maybe I'll just pop off and that'll be
the end of it
or I'll die while using six vials and we
go again tomorrow
it's a lot of Hope
gonna go get a few more bullets from
this gonad down here almost fell to my
death
not him you
okay
final attempts
can I clutch out
the answer is more than likely
no
I Can Dream
I can prevail
have faith chat
have faith
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I thought he was stuck on the Rock like
he was at the first part of that attack
and then he went through the Rock
and then I was [ __ ]
current level 78.
probably too low
ask me if I care
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know how you react to that I
really don't
I thought that was way too early and I
backed off
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I don't [ __ ] get it man
[Music]
I don't understand
that [ __ ] tracks me down is
forever
I'm out in the middle of the [ __ ]
ocean
I gotta try one more time I'm so in this
right now
I I am so invested
I mean do I just keep running like I was
or what do I do like do I just keep
going because it looks like it's never
gonna stop
ever
damn dillian here's for your good work
today I've not seen one Super Chat
that's a 20 Super Chat holy
[ __ ] dude thank you man that's huge
thank you very much
I don't know if I'm working hard but I'm
out here working that's for sure
thank you dude that's really really kind
of weird
I just run as far as I can I was running
to the like didn't you see me turn my
camera around and I'm running I see my
little window and I run over to the side
and it it's it it's like it gets bigger
like it expands
I will say
can I dodge through it
because some of you have said that and I
I don't know if I believe you
[Applause]
I see the gaps
they're just over there and by the time
they get to me I can't get over there to
the left or right
not looking for Echoes bro I'm not
looking for Echoes I'm not gonna go to
come [ __ ] whatever it's called I'm not
doing it stop telling me to do that chat
timing's really tricky okay thank you
got it
it's been two hours
since I started fighting cause
and I fought Millennia for six five five
or six
something like that
I dude hey guys everyone everyone type
come dungeon please I just want that in
my chat
and every time someone says it I'm gonna
say no
no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no
okay I'm done I'm over it
imagine my parents watching right now
and they just hear me say everyone typed
on come dungeon I want that in my chat
imagine
why did I leave I'm good
why'd I leave what am I doing
what am I doing
if only I could just fast travel like an
Elden ring that'd be great remaster this
game with Elden ring fast travel and I
will poop my pants
all this all this [ __ ]
foreign
what the [ __ ]
and I'll be like you don't understand
my parents watched my streams all the
time
focusing focusing in
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah
that's really unfortunate
I'm gonna die to a swing again
[Music]
[Music]
nuts
can I get some nuts in chat
nuts
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
hi
yes go for it
okay thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
no no
no
no
no no
no
[Applause]
no
no
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
more with the chat right now than with
the boss
foreign
but some people
need to shut the [ __ ] up
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
foreign
[Applause]
wow
sign I try again
guys I could go level up
I could go do whatever the [ __ ] you guys
are telling me to do
I could
I won't
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh that one hurt
what the [ __ ] I need those oh man
oh dude I was so I was so in it
it was right [ __ ] there dude I think
if he does anything
else because there's no way I'm running
away from that like people spam like run
into the ocean
I'm right next to him dude
I tried to dodge through the timing
potentially to to get it but
it didn't happen
doing so good and then he just starts
spamming man he really does
guys stop telling me to level up I can
clearly do it like this
clearly it's very possible
so no
I don't know if I can
hold on let me text this
hold on
yeah no [ __ ] it's hard it's fine
foreign
yeah I I second phase I do not see a
Perry window at all
not one bit
I'm sure they're in there but I mean I'm
looking at it and I'm like ah I don't
know
off
this this boss is uh
I really like the boss a lot like the
learning learning this boss is awesome
but the
in insanely difficult but
fair I would say like I feel like every
time I die it's mostly my fault
there are a lot of Perry windows in the
second phase maybe try and experiment a
couple times
really there are a lot and then some
other guy comes in and says there's only
one so
I don't personally see it like as I'm
playing I'm like uh
uh
yeah it's just difficult
no other way around it man
it's just hard
no cap
it's hard
ain't nothing wrong with hard
would you guys say the recommended level
was
really a hundred
well that's fine
I did not mean to come here whoops
I'm all over the place
I'm level 78 okay
okay
I wanna have one more good attempt I
really do
what if it's been hard for more than
four hours I mean that's not even that
long dude
you know it is what it is
sometimes shit's hard
why would I go see a doctor
yeah I got water I'm drinking I'm good
it didn't go well at level 60.
I wouldn't imagine
yeah
[Music]
oh I see if it's hard for more than four
hours
probably should go see a doctor
I've just seen it
like while I'm doing it I'm not kidding
guys I'm while I'm playing I'm like I
could do this without getting hit a
single time
and I'm like weirdly like I like doing
[ __ ] like perfectly
if I can
now I'm like trying to do that it's
probably not a good idea
13's enough
we go now
yeah I just gotta do it man and I'm like
sometimes in that zone
and uh he does all the attacks that I
like and then I can Parry it and
visceral and attack and Dodge and we're
all good and then Sage 2 comes along and
I'm like I'm [ __ ] here we go
typical that's fine
this will be the last
temps however
I know my mental limit
I see you're saying toxic
to you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Brandon I appreciate that
[Applause]
the first attempt after going to farm
always goes bad every time
that that timing of his attacks there
just could not have been worse and of
course he he I mean he kills me in two
hits so
that sucks
I'm gonna go get some more bullets real
quick
I'm glad you like it Rick I am dying
inside but I'm okay that's pretty
obvious
okay we're all here to sing this
we're all here to see the streamer die
inside
are you normal
what the [ __ ] are you I don't want this
[ __ ]
[ __ ] what the
me
all right you want to kill me do it do
it [ __ ]
you think I care I don't
I don't
dude if I don't do this now it's gonna
take all day tomorrow too
foreign
you got him regardless we're gonna get
him the juice is worth the squeeze I
agree
thank you for another five dollars I
really appreciate that thank you
thank you for the bullets as well
surprise you got some blood gems
[Music]
look at that nightmare Frontier is here
hola
let's get wacky
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the first stage could I have done better
how many times did I Parry him in the
first stage
how many times perfectly
and then stage two is like
I'm I'm seven years old in an NBA
basketball game
getting Dunked On by LeBron James
I mean my God
thank you Tommy
[Applause]
foreign
wow
he just healed getting that little combo
and it's over if I if I get staggered
and he's in some kind of combo it's you
you die
you just die you are no longer alive
off Tempo it is kind of like a dance
and if the dance is off it's bad dance
[Music]
my character is just currently not
dodging he just didn't move I'm pressing
the Dodge button and he's not doing it I
don't understand the [ __ ] and then I'm
caught in the combo and I die [ __ ]
Christ
oh
we're still playing man
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
such [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
did he just do it twice
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
oh my God it happened
oh my God
[Music]
it [ __ ] happened
holy [ __ ]
oh
[Music]
holy [ __ ] Dylan
enjoy yourself and King has remedy
together
let's go
a hundred dollar Super Chat
holy [ __ ] dude thank you oh my God
you won
I did oh wait that yeah I did win
and then Brandon with the five dollars
too thank you guys
Dylan that's a hundred bucks that's a
lot of [ __ ] money dude
thank you you're insane
Brandon thank you as well for sure
holy crap
finally
thank you Angel as well
thank you
thank you guys
oh my God I lost my mind did you guys
notice that I lost my [ __ ] mind
like
maybe two hours ago
what is this
let's go
I don't have nightmares oh
ah I had to go a little mentally insane
Sweet Child Of course
returned to the ocean you're good Dylan
it's probably a good idea to level up
a bottomless sea
accepting of all that there is
and can be
what just happened
is that all the DLC
I lifted the curves purse orphan spirit
is free now
I did it
is this one of the great ones
go back to corpse and look for weapon
there's a corpse
didn't I kill him in the middle of the
ocean
oh yeah I got the parasite
yeah I got it
I didn't I didn't it wasn't a weapon it
was just like a looked like a rune Maybe
okay
okay
well hopefully that was worth the watch
guys and me going mentally insane
I don't know how many super chats we got
today but it was actually nuts I really
appreciate it
thank you
we are obviously gonna finish this
tomorrow
[Laughter]
how long when did I start cause like
three hours ago
three four hours
together
my boy did it late reaction was bossy on
hands
quite bossy sir thank you for the dollar
I appreciate it
we're gonna finish this tomorrow we also
have a sponsored stream with rage Shadow
Legends tomorrow so we're gonna do this
for a bit
and then we're gonna or actually we'll
probably beat the game and then we're
gonna do our sponsored stream and
that'll be the stream tomorrow
so that'll be fun hopefully you guys
will come out for that should be fun
I've never played raid Shadow Legends
before
and if you like it or not you can come
and tell me
I'd appreciate it
so
that's it for me today
because I'm [ __ ] exhausted and I'm
hungry
I'm gonna go get some food that's a
seven hour stream right there people
damn
half of it was on
orphan of costs
um you can add me dillian Dylan sorry
it's the same as my YouTube name if you
want
I don't I don't usually like go on Steam
that much I'm always on Discord
anyway
have a great rest of your day guys thank
you all for the insane support today
you're all nuts thank you
um
yeah I'm gonna go eat
that's a dub I didn't think we were
gonna get that done I'm not gonna lie I
thought that it might not be possible
but here we are doing it so thank you
guys appreciate all the support we'll be
back tomorrow hope you'll come out for
the sponsored stream I'd really
appreciate it if you did
and I'll see you all then
peace and love
bye bye bye